this should really come as absolutely no
surprise to any of us but the leading
republican gov gubernatorial recall
candidate in the california
gubernatorial recall
is not saying he will accept the results
and in fact seems to have already
conceded defeat and has launched an
initiative to say that we need to
recount or something like that the daily
beast is reporting larry elder
preemptively concedes defeat and
launches a voter fraud site
before the results of today's california
gubernatorial recall have even come in
top polling republican candidate larry
elder appeared to be already conceding
defeat on monday and preparing to blame
his loss on baseless claims of
widespread voter fraud as first reported
by the sacramento bee
elder's campaign launched a website
calling for his supporters to report
incidents of voter fraud and sign a
petition to investigate the results wait
hold on you're calling for an
investigation before the results are out
the site which is paid for by the
campaign includes language that assumes
governor newsom has already won although
no results have yet been released and
elder is campaigning
the site says quote we implore you to
join us in this fight as you were able
primarily by signing our petition
demanding a special session of the
california legislature to investigate
and ameliorate the twisted results of
this recall wait we don't have the
results yet you're calling for
for some kind of uh investigation of the
results that we don't yet have
it goes on to say additionally the
website states statistical analyses used
to detect fraud in elections held in
third world nations such as russia
venezuela and iran have detected fraud
in california resulting in governor
newsom being reinstated as governor
by the way reinstated he was never
removed
it's all crazy and it really shouldn't
surprise us here was larry elder
yesterday being asked multiple times
will you commit to accepting the results
and he won't say that he will because he
obviously will not
larry elder the leading republican
candidate would not commit to accepting
the results of the election yeah
again whether or not you win or lose
will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow no i think we all
ought to be looking at election
integrity no matter whether you're a
democrat an independent or republican
let's all make sure that the election is
a fair election until this all work
together no sir do you have any reason
to believe that it is not fair as of
right now do you have any evidence what
the results are to make sure that the
results are valid and legitimate and
everybody who voted should have voted
let's all do that together is that a
commitment to accept the results of the
election tomorrow let's all do that
together let's all work together uh on
both sides of the aisle to make sure
that the election is a fair election
yeah i would like to see the actual
question
is there anything right now that you can
point to that makes you doubt the
integrity of this election donald trump
i mean it shouldn't surprise us larry
elder is doing this i played for you
this clip last week donald trump on
newsmax is already saying it's rigged in
california as the polling has gone more
and more in favor of gavin newsom
the claims of rigging have increased
got the recall election coming up in
less than a week uh it's actually
happening as we speak the polls appear
to show newsome look safer at this point
larry elder is the man uh that could
take it from him what do you think
happens in california yeah well it's
probably rigged they're sending out all
ballots it's all uh the the ballots are
you know mail out mail-in ballots in
fact i guess you even have a case where
you can make your own ballot when that
happens uh in crayon you can make your
own ballot nobody's gonna win except
these democrats so you know look they're
very good the one thing they're good at
is rigging elections so i predict it's a
rigged election let's see how it turns
out so there is of course no evidence of
that whatsoever but they are already
claiming fraud already claiming fraud
let's hope that uh
larry elder does not become the governor
of california it would be a real tragedy
i see it as a partial referendum on
trumpism elder a big pro-trump guy big
big pro-trump guy um and keeping newsome
would not only be better for california
than putting in larry elder
who says there should be no minimum wage
he i mean listen i can't we went through
the whole list on a stream yesterday um
and has said he would end any kind of
mass requirements any kind of vaccine
requirements end everything and trump's
great
um
let's hope that that doesn't happen
tonight you can join me live on youtube
twitch and facebook
for
results from california
tonight okay
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 off and free shipping when you go
to 4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video